nice to see you to see you sir bruce
forsyth was one of Britain's best and
most popular all-round entertainers it's
called organs of the body all right
singing dancing and charming the country
and the cameras for over 70 years
[Applause]
his comedy and catchphrases a huge part
of Saturday night television for
generations it's nice to see you to see
you it's been a marvelous around I mean
I've had disappointments big
disappointments and then I've had great
highs and that's what a career is all
about you get over the lows and look
forward to the highs and when you get
the highs enjoy it as much as you can
and that's been what I've done all the
time
[Music]
there's nobody in the history of British
show business who has endured and worked
as hard as he has but endured in the
public's affection with succeeding
generation after generation it's
staggering it's a staggering staggering
achievement that will never ever ever be
surpassed sir bruce got his big break
comparing Sunday night at the London
Palladium in 1958 but he'd been
performing since the age of 14 and did
years on stage doing summer seasons and
panto okay look for a Brucie bonus
there's one there it might not look very
much but it's worth more than what it
looks like his first big hit there's a
generation game he'd found his home on
primetime TV and it's where he stayed
for the next 30 years he had this
amazing ability to take the mickey out
of the public but make the public enjoy
the experience and he had that great
warmth he was such a big star he could
survive a complete car crash he did a
show for ITV called Bruce's big night it
was a disaster everything about it was
terrible but he survived that most
people would have gone under he came
back even stronger
hosting shows played to all his
strengths
[Music]
his comic timing not to mention his
ability to sing and dance made him
hugely popular with the public
there is a unique gift given to a rare
few the ability to come through the
screen to communicate a human warmth to
inspire in the audience that feeling of
they're in safe hands and this is a
master of his craft he had it in
abundance these gifts combined with his
charity work earned him an OBE CBA
and eventually a knighthood children you
see him grown up with me since I was
when I was 30 years old when I did the
Palladium children were going growing
out with me and all the years since then
now with strictly children love the show
lettuce I get from different kids with
drawings and testimony and they are your
audience that go on forever and I think
they've the children are the people in
this world that have helped me go on
forever being me the world of good this
show 76 instead of retiring so Bruce
made his big TV comeback with Strictly
Come Dancing it was a job he relished
for 11 seasons bring him a whole new
following and will sing his way into the
record books for the longest career in
TV entertainment history
Sir Bruce Forsyth was one of the last
old school variety acts for seven
decades he entertained his public and
didn't he do Wow Lisa gossips I news
[Applause]